Somewhere tonight, in the Verizon center in
Washington DC, magic will happen.
Maybe not here.
But maybe here, or here, or here. And definitely
here.
The kiss cam's magic doesn't happen by chance.
They have to select the kissers, keep a few
secrets, and work an arena crowd, not just
a couple. The kiss cam is the story of a high-tech
theatrical production and a business model,
falling in love.
A few decks above the court is a guy locked
into a headset.
Zak Grim's the manager of
game entertainment.
"Anything that happens in the arena bowl on
a game night that is not the game of basketball
is kind of my domain."
That means he's cutting through the activity
of a game night to find the right couples.
"We are the ones that kind of execute it.
So we create all the graphics that go around
it, we're on headset trying to pick out where
all the couples are in the crowd, saying 'Oh,
section 220 looks like it's got a lot of good
people in it. Put a camera on that, let's
find a couple there.' So we're the ones actually
executing it."
And Zak's always connected to somebody in
the windowless control room on the ground
floor — somebody who's put a president and
the first lady on the kiss cam.
"I was the one who did that, yes."
Quentin, Q for short, has a feed of every
camera constantly ready, and he's locked into
cameramen who can give him options. He cuts
between them as Zak fills each discrete programming
segment, from the Wizard Girls, to the money
machine, to the kiss cam, making the whole
night a production with a ton of moving parts.
All that effort only makes sense because the
kiss cam isn't an accident — it's a business
model made for modern sports.
The history of the kiss cam is recent, but
hazy. Some people credit the Dodgers, others
think the Marlins came up with it at some
point in the early 90s. And it makes sense,
because nobody knew kiss cams would become...a
phenomenon. But, in some ways, they were a
foregone conclusion.
Arenas have big incentives to maximize revenue
in the facility. That money's often kept in
a different pot from the NBA and sometimes
the arena and team are separate entities.
So that's why you see a bevy of sponsored
fan packages, sponsored blimps, LED wraparounds
courtesy of large banks, and, though basketball
fans are passionate about the folk dances
of the Republic of Turkey, you're probably
only seeing it thanks to a check from Etihad
Airlines.
And that's why the kiss cam is sponsored too.
Videoboards —Jumbotron's the branded term
— are a big and shiny example of arenas'
profit centers.
"They are powerful sales tools in serving
ads to fans, basically, and they're also part
of sponsorship deals. Because of the location,
fans are a captive audience and they are amazingly
effective at getting the attention of people
in the arena.
And that's one reason they put so much work
into making the kiss cam click. If a couple
doesn't kiss, that's not a bad thing.
"We'll come back to them."
"Hold on, we're gonna come back."
Whatever makes for a good show is a good kiss.
"Go back."
"Go back. See...there you go."
The kiss cam is part of a sponsored package
with two audiences — the fans, and the people
who pay for it.
"Let's go to our people, Q."
The occasional plant happens too.
"Ready to unleash."
But usually, the love is legitimate. What
happens in Verizon Center is not a game. It's
different every time because new people want
their shot at video board glory.
"There you go. Oh gosh. Three underneath...dissolve."
"One more after them Q, one more after them."
There's no referee here, just applause.
"What is this usher doing?"
"He's giving them certificates. OK, let 'em
kiss. We're gonna stay with them. Honey, honey
look!"
"Beautiful. Fade music."
"Go clean."
"Great way to end it, perfect."
It's a professional show put on by people
at the top of their field to make fans happy
and bring in a lot of cash.
Oh. There's a basketball game too.
"One of the workers came and asked if we would
do this little skit on the kiss cam."
"All we had to do was be prepared for her
to be pulled out of the camera and there'd
be a lot of silly string. She thought he was
furry and cute, so I was like, I hope he doesn't
steal my girl."